you gotta be ready to do some winning on
a catch rook not a 1 p.m. star both of
these teams trying to impose their will
early Westbrook with a left hand
underneath on I like how both teams
their energy right now
here's a three and short here's the
three the other way Melo makes it now
the Thunder leave this right here the
missed shot watch this rebound pitch
Jimmy I mean that's a one on three
affray from Durham he's got a victim
authorize a penalty but if anyone would
he with that here's Westbrook slicing
through runner short three minutes left
here
Westbrook on a dime to Adams in 20 wants
a timeout I can imagine the kentucky
wildcat product turnover deflection in
Westbrook and the largest
that time just out of control Norman
Powell that time trying to make things
up it's when they get it off of
turnovers and get out and Iran very much
like we say the problem is they've
turned it over six times bills out
here's Westbrook speeding ahead and
Brewer at the line and that's why they
get up in through is a great pick up for
them Westbrook backing in is it dad
Adams tack to Westbrook out of post up
Westbrook 9.7 dimes already 1964 when
the Raptors get a stop here
Westbrook finds George wide-open
accolade
point-7 they run into each other on the
baseline air and Westbrook steps back
from Lowry in scores and brings the
Thunder back within one possession now
you want to stop let's shoot us at
double figures again to the basket
Adams quickness been 22 right now you're
gonna get stopped you got a chance his
second of a three so hurdle in for JP
turning away Westbrook will head to the
line come on right a young player is
right here
11 points eight assists for him played
well here's Westbrook have greenness
afraid sticks it who the pumping right
he's on ice for three quarters he comes
in and the fourth knocks down two big
admit best fourth point
fourth quarter shooter from three-point
range
his miles and then Westbrook stand he
said with a long three
here's by one triple-double now
Westbrook doesn't go gets his own
rebound all batted in the rebound on
this send the Lowery one of your better
rebound is this shot and obviously
follows it up Westbrook
balint Eunice
Westbrook
attacking lemon hand good illegal play
that time by in the game and again now
the pocket is time switches gets back
and then look at that little pin by game
for him offensive Lee and Westbrook
Hey we're gonna write here Adams little
elbow there at DeRozan Westbrook upon
Westbrook jumper back sit in timeout
with us today look at it right here
again Steven Adams with another screen
assist